turnovers shut [ __ ] fine apart goes
right at his right hand left with his
team to play it and not too much of
fast-break titled increased pace but
just look at that ultra check clip a
nice job nice be nice finish
which is led to 10 Houston points
because they sit the started favors as
you see you gotta force out to the right
Petula his sniff gives it up leave aunty
honest let's say again goddess goddess
to play Baker to the swipe over to knock
it away
donc riding it out about lunchtime
relying on the scoops there's hard to
put the water they have
[Music]
but just amplify the bits clears
cattitude sterling Brown 39 of the 58
points from the big three and now
six to try to play him physically and
then steps back steps in front of her
but hardly with a step back Lopez finds
Yanis he sees a wall seven beds down
Maris
boys to throttle so impressive here in
the second quarter
[Music]
well to be honest it didn't get more
fish back the tendon
[Applause]
Justin Wetzel steps in front of this
why don't you run here by the Jazz with
the water
has presented some issues for the Bucks
held a bustin with 20 points in the
quarter
I need the gone again some tickets
[Music]
[Applause]
close that position when he's been
trying to
eh-eh
you know that's yes
[Applause]